I stand before you today-
-to say these words.
I announce my candidacy for President of the
United States of America.
Nearly a dozen Democrats are already running
for president
and highlights so far include an interview
about immigration
live-streamed from a dental chair,
a former Harvard professor popping a beer
like jes’ plain folks on New Year’s Eve
and a draconian former prosecutor pledging
her allegiance to Wakanda.
Payed for by Kamala Harris.
Democrats are tripping over each other to
pitch Medicare for All, Free College for All,
Jobs for All, and laying taxes on wealth as
well as income.
And then there’s Howard Schultz.
I think the Democrats need a little bit less
caffeine right now.
The former CEO of Starbucks,announced that
he is considering a run for president
as a “centrist independent.”
He says that the national debt threatens economic
growth,
that we shouldn’t demonize successful entrepreneurs,
and that the government can’t be all things
to all people.
Both parties are consistently not doing what's
necessary on behalf of the American people
and are engaged every single day in revenge
politics.
That brought public hate, contempt, and character
assassination
from every conceivable angle.
It’s not just anti-globalist lefties on
the attack.
The New York Times op-ed page says he’s
narcissistic, delusional, and fanatical.
His potential run, his critics claim, would
be nothing short of “reckless idiocy.”
Schultz’s belief that neither major party
represents America is widely shared.
A plurality of Americans don’t identify
with either party.
And nearly three-quarters of us think the
country is headed in the wrong direction,
which helps to explain why neither Hillary
Clinton nor Donald Trump
won a majority of the popular vote in 2016.
The two-party duopoly and its supporters in
the media
understand how widely disliked they are,
which is why they want to kneecap anyone who
isn’t on Team Red or Team Blue.
You don’t have to agree with Schultz
to understand that having more ideas and more voices at the table
at this point in the election cycle is a good
thing,
especially when you consider the alternatives.
Democrats fear people such as Schultz
because they think he will drain votes whoever
their nominee ends up being,
giving Trump a path to re-election.
But that’s actually faulty analysis.
Former Republican Congressman John Anderson
was blamed for pulling votes from Jimmy Carter
in 1980,
but almost half his supporters would have
gone with Ronald Reagan as their second choice.
In 1992, the GOP fingered Ross Perot as a
political saboteur,
but in fact the 19 percent of Americans who
pulled the lever for the Texas Billionaire
were equally split between Bush and Clinton
as their fallback.
If variety in armpit aroma isn’t his thing,
I’d like to believe that the Vermont socialist
still believes we should have more choice
at the ballot box.
Right now, there are more forms of hepatitis
than viable political parties in America.
So it’s kind of fitting that the former
CEO of a company
that introduced infinite choice in coffee
drinks
is now being dragged for threatening to expand
the political spectrum
all the way from A to C.
If American politics can’t stand even the
possibility of an independent candidate
who praises capitalism, opposes massive tax
increases,
and wants to cut federal debt, we’re already
screwed in 2020.